or l'offre au milk of le choix est
difficile pour cette famille habitant à
saint martin de brett en cours ils ont
fait la route jusqu'à airs meurent et
pour accueillir un nouveau membre dans
leur famille pendant des années j'ai eu
des chaque l'agent n'avait plus à la
maison et du coup j'avais 13 ans et de
ravoir un chat et du coup choisir la spa
parce que ben vaut mieux quand dans
chaque a été abandonnée ou pas forcément
bien traités
j'avais regardé un petit peu sur
internet dont j'avais eu quelques coups
de coeur malheureusement certains sont
déjà réservées donc maintenant je vais
choisir entre ceux qui restent et fille
qu'il aime bien le plus ce refuge peut
accueillir jusqu'à 100 chat et son chien
les 16 salariés et la quinzaine de
bénévoles aident à la rencontre et
pourquoi pas au coup de foudre lors de
cette saint valentin des animaux c'est
de faire adopter un maximum bien
évidemment mais ça j'ai envie de dire
c'est notre lot au quotidien c'est
plutôt une rencontre se faire connaître
dans le sens par en tant que refuge
propre mais en tant que spa et avoir des
échanges avec les gens leur expliquer un
petit peu notre métier qu'est ce qu'on
fait exactement comment ça se pratique
la spa cherche toujours des bénévoles et
des familles pour s'occuper de leurs
protégés environ cent mille animaux
seraient abandonnés chaque année milk of
lui a trouvé un nouveau foyer